and as cases climb here locally testing
sites are also expanding around the
valley
the goal of course is to make testing
more convenient and detect the virus
before it spreads hector mejia
is live near lake mead and mlk with the
very latest on those efforts hey hector
hey there alex and the health district
says they just want to make things
easier they're bringing testing into
neighborhoods you do not need an
appointment and you also
do not need to have any symptoms to get
yourself a test and here at doolittle
community center
the first round of workers are arriving
getting things ready to open at eight
this morning and they're staying open
until noon this is one of three
neighborhood cove 19 testing sites
available through the southern nevada
health district over the next few weeks
they hope that increased testing will
slow the current trend we're seeing
that trend is going up and here's why
they tell us early detection is so
important
experts say a big percentage of those
infected with the coronavirus
have only minor symptoms or no symptoms
at all
those symptoms include fever cough
shortness of breath among others
and the health district here well they
have several other locations around the
valley we've been to the thomas and max
center the cashman center in texas
station
last week governor steve sisilak
announced that he found out he had
coveted
through routine testing he said he was
not feeling any symptoms at the time but
mentioned
he was feeling fatigue earlier in the
week and testing here again
starts at 8 this morning and the site is
centrally located just off of
mlk and lake mead boulevard reporting
live this morning hector mejia
8 news now